bonsoir merci de nous rejoindre sur tv
fil 78 pour une nouvelle édition du
journal de la rédaction voici les titres
de ce lundi 6 juillet le référendum greg
secoue l'europe et dans les yvelines à
la verrière un rassemblement a eu lieu à
l'appel d'élus de gauche quelques heures
avant la victoire du non les
organisateurs souhaitaient s'unir
distille contre le refus des banquiers
d'entendre la souffrance des peuples
alors que le premier week-end de départ
en vacances vient de se terminer
l'association 40 millions
d'automobilistes a lancé une opération
pour tester nos connaissances du code de
la route mais parlons également des
nouvelles interdictions volant avec le
directeur départemental de la prévention
routière et puis à magny les hameaux
sixième édition de l'opération rtt
remets tes tongs du 6 au 13 juillet dans
le quartier du buisson des animations
sportives et culturelles également les
échos du mouvement en grec se font
entendre jusque dans les yvelines samedi
matin à l'appel de plusieurs
responsables politiques de gauche
notamment de la mairie pcf de la
verrière des habitants se sont
rassemblés avec pour slogan la volonté
de dénoncer la politique impérialiste de
l'union européenne mélanie poker étaient
sur place
on a pensé que c'était un moment
suffisamment important important pour
les grecs mais pas seulement pour les
grecs important pour l'europe important
pour notre pays est suffisamment
important pour qu'on ait envie de
marquer notre soutien et notre
solidarité samedi matin plein du
scarabée à la verrière à 24 heures du
référendum les citoyens élus verts
hyérois ont voulu marquer le coup et se
sont rassemblés pour échanger sur la
situation grecque
ce qu'on demande c'est que d'abord la
vie des peuples soient respectées les
grecs ont élu un gouvernement sur la
base d'un programme très majoritaire
dans ce programme il y avait le refus de
l'austérité y avait des propositions
concrètes tout le monde dit il
les grecs veulent uniquement le
gouvernement de l'agglo uniquement
l'effacement de la dette c'est pas du
tout ça il ya le gouvernement grec veut
une réadaptation de cette dette
la reconnaissance d'une partie légitime
de la dette et puis évidemment des
mesures qui permettent à la grèce de
retrouver un nouveau départ une pétition
et une lettres ont été adressées au
président de la république
nestor nestori dix étudiants l'économie
nombre de syrie à paris et témoins
directs de la crise que traverse son
pays étaient présents pour expliquer la
situation grecque le niveau de vie a
fortement baissé à cause des politiques
d'austérité imposé par l'union
européenne et par lé fmi par la troïka
par exemple le les salaires ont
fortement baissé plus de 30%
on a eu une pause in hausse des impôts
énorme et en plus le taux de chômage a
fortement augmenté à 30% et 60% pour la
jeunesse une cinquantaine de veyrier roy
avaient fait le déplacement ce samedi
le référendum grec a vu le non l'emporté
hier soir avec plus de 61% des voix
l'association 40 millions
d'automobilistes lance aujourd'hui
l'opération 100 questions pour la route
afin de tester nos connaissances les
connaissances des conducteurs français
bonsoir jean yves petit elle soit le
directeur départemental de l'association
de prévention routière l'apn traître un
mot sur ce dispositif qui vient d'être
lancé il ya des vraies lacunes
aujourd'hui autour des connaissances du
code de la route
je pense que les gens qui ont passé le
code de la route depuis un certain temps
on oublié certaines certains points
c'est évident mais maintenant le les
mesures principales les règles
principales du code de la route sont
connus heureusement mais il ya quand
même pas mal qui sont un peu oubliés
est ce qui est pointé du doigt c'est
l'absence de formation continue
justement vous l'avez dit on passe son
permis et puis ensuite on n'a plus
besoin de se soucier du code de la route
finalement qu'on le connaisse ou qu'on
ne connaissent pas est ce que vous êtes
favorable avec votre association à la
mise en place d'un temps en temps d'un
petit contrôle continu une petite piqûre
de rappel autour du code de la route
tous les cinq ans par exemple tout va
tourner et oui ça serait bien évidemment
mais tout va tourner autour du
financement de cette mesure
comme d'habitude qui va payer donc ça va
résoudre la question assez rapidement
j'en ai peur mais si on met de côté la
question de l'argent sera quasi
certainement une bonne chose oui ça peut
se faire de façon volontaire d'ailleurs
dans notre site internet
la prévention routière nous avons des
tests du code de la route il ya ce sont
des choses qui existent par internet
l'initiative de 40 millions
d'automobilistes est une bonne
initiative
oui il ya certainement beaucoup de
choses à faire mais si on veut instituer
ça avec les auto-écoles les
professionnels il va falloir déterminer
qui paie on voit les images de ce site
internet si vous voulez faire le test
une centaine de questions dans la
première version les yaks une dizaine de
questions vous pouvez toujours faire ce
test avec des résultats pas forcément
toujours très encourageant je vous
donnerai pas ma note à l'issue de ce
test de connaissance en tout cas nous
sommes allés dans la rue cet après midi
avec quelques panneaux de signalisation
vous poser cette question les
connaissez-vous tout simplement voici
quelques réponses de ce test grandeur
nature
ça va dit que celle là c'est un délit et
c'est là c'était interdit
le premier s'est point point de vue
prévu et le deuxième c'est interdit aux
véhicules
je ne sais pas je n'ai aucune idée
honnêtement aucune idée ça c'est quand
il ya un point de vue sur la sur la
ville et ça c'est ça c'est
l'interdiction interdiction je dirais il
est conseillé d'éclairer les banques ont
peut-être fait pas sens interdit
franchement j'ai oublié ça allait mais
le faisant dans les pays de l'est mais
les part je crois d faire du bruit non
le klaxon non non je sais pas c'est à
dire qu'il ya un point de vue et ça ça
veut dire que c'est interdit à toute
circulation
vélo tout aucun véhicule peut circuler
voilà pour les bonnes réponses sont les
dernières le site question pour la route
point com lancé par 40 millions
d'automobilistes
il ya ces panneaux et puis les aussi
quelques questions j'en ai forcément
quelques unes pour vous questions à
choix multiples la nuit par temps clair
hors agglomération sur route non
éclairée
je peux circuler en feux de position en
feux de croisement et feux de route en
feux de position et feux de brouillard
avant tous feux éteints a complètement
oublié le début de la nuit par temps
clair hors agglomération sur route non
éclairée
quels sont les flots qu'il faut allumer
les feux de croisement voilà est à 90 km
h sur route mouillée distance d'arrêt
d'une voiture 50 mètre 90 m 120 m 150 m
alors j'espère que vous avez la bonne
réponse parce que je ne vais pas en plus
gelé rappelé tout à l'heure dans une
entreprise 90 km route mouillée
vous avez dit quoi 50 90 120 ou 150 90
je vous laissera aller vérifier sur
internet j'ai pas la bonne réponse je
comptais sur vous je pensais que vous
étiez infaillible c'est pas toujours
évident ce test et c'est toujours bien
pour se rafraîchir un peu la mémoire
on va profiter de votre passage en
plateau pour évoquer aussi votre
initiative avec l'apn par et pour les
vacances
un guide avec des conseils justement par
exemple quels sont les conseils dans ce
guide paris pour les vacances alors donc
c'est avec plusieurs partenaires de la
prévention routière
un guide qui va être distribué
dans les centres de nos partenaires et
en particulier le 10 juillet sur les
aires d'autoroute de morinville il sur
l'a13
ce sont des conseils de bon sens en
particulier au moment du départ en
vacances je voudrais si vous le
permettez ont rappelé 5
pour ce qui me concerne 2 qui concerne
le véhicule
premièrement bien charger sa voiture
c'est à dire les objets volumineux les
grosses valises les mâles dans le fond
sur l'avant de façon à éviter qu'elles
soient projetés sur l'avant en k2 en cas
de freinage brusque
ça c'est pour le chargement de la
voiture deuxièmement les contrôles à
effectuer sur le véhicule
la pression des pneus l'huile le liquide
le la vitre et c'est qu'ici les fait à
peu près correctement sur la voiture que
l'on utilise tous les jours les
peut-être moins sur la caravane le
camping car ou la remorque que qu'on ne
sort qu'une fois par an donc bien
contrôler l'état de ses véhicules
ça c'est pour les véhicules est
maintenant sur la conduite elle même je
voudrais rappeler que sur autoroute
selon le code de la route on roule le
plus à droite possible on ne reste pas
collé sur la voie du milieu
surtout si on roule moins vite que le
flot des autres voitures ce qui n'est
pas interdit évidemment mais on roule le
plus à droite possible et enfin
je voudrais rappeler un conseil sur les
français pour un conseil c'est la règle
sur les distances de sécurité qu'il faut
respecter entre deux véhicules
et comme à l'occasion de ces grands
départs en vacances il est impossible de
respecter les distances de sécurité
puisqu'il ya trop de voitures tout
simplement matériellement on peut pas
respectés alors levant le pied et
soignants d'autant plus vigilant qu'on
sait bien qu'on ne peut pas respecter
les distances de sécurité et qu'il faut
freiner et que ça prend de la distance
pour phone et même si je me suis trompé
tout à l'heure mais il ya une certaine
distance il faut mieux garder un espace
de sécurité obligatoire vous l'avez
rappelé a même pas juste un conseil
c'est obligatoire plus de la moitié des
automobilistes 59% selon les différents
sondages qui ne procède pas aux
contrôles essentielles sur leur voiture
vous avez rappelé quelques règles mais
c'est important de contrôler son
véhicule lorsqu'on s'apprête à faire des
grands chemins des grandes routes ben
oui ça peut éviter
des désagréments par forcément
l'accident mais des désagréments ne
serait-ce que si on appuie l'eau dans le
dans la vitre bon c'est désagréable
et puis ça peut éviter des accidents
aussi 1,6 un pneu éclate
parce que il est pas bien gonflés ou qui
les usagers sur sa remorque et qu'on n'a
pas contrôler ça peut être sa part des
conséquences d'un oui c'est important
qu'il ya des rappels réguliers qui sont
faits par les différentes associations
notamment la prévention routière est ce
que ces dernières années ça a une
incidence sur les sur le comportement
des automobilistes est ce qu'il y a
moins d'accidents ces dernières années
quels sont les chiffres les tendances à
les tendances malheureusement sont la
tendance n'est pas très bonne depuis
l'année dernière depuis 2014 nous avons
une recrudescence du nombre de tués sur
les routes en france pas forcément du
nombre de blessés mais du nombre de tués
et pour les six premiers mois de l'année
la tendance malheureusement n'est pas
très bonne non plus puisqu'on a une
légère augmentation du nombre de tués
sur les routes par rapport à 2014
y compris dans notre département aussi
d'ailleurs donc toute façon là la
période d'été est malheureusement
jaillir propice peut-être pas le terme
mais voit malheureusement beaucoup
d'accidents puisque à beaucoup plus de
monde sur les routes tous usagers
confondues les piétons les vélos les
tout le monde donc il ya plus de risques
d'avoir des accidents d'ailleurs les
vélos vous donner aussi des conseils
pratiques pour les vélos sur votre site
internet
la prévention routière intervient aussi
là dessus parce qu'il fait beau et il
sent le vélo aux examens en vacances
avec son vélo et la voisine ou la
prévention routière s'adresse à tous les
usagers de la voie publique du piéton
jusqu'au conducteur de poids lourd même
si on s'adresse un peu moins aux
conducteurs professionnels mais piétons
cyclistes moto beaucoup moto
automobilistes quelques conseils pour
les vélos pour les vélos oui alors le
conseil que je rappelle c'est porter un
casque l'acceptant abattoirs de porter
un cas c'est pas obligatoire sauf enfin
en france c'est pas obligatoire en
espagne ça l'est déjà c'est obligatoire
celle où dans une circonstance qui a
lieu en ce moment les courses cyclistes
il ya dix ans il vaut mieux tourner
france il n'avait pas de casque
aujourd'hui ils en ont tous
obligatoirement ça nous arrivera
probablement
pour tout le monde un mot sur les
différentes interdictions au volant il
ya des nouvelles interdictions depuis le
1er juillet la première des
interdictions c'est une de ne plus du
tout manipulé de téléphone portable
lorsqu'on conduit à petites mains libres
sauf le bluetooth dans l'est dans les
voitures interdit de manger un sandwich
aussi par exemple se maquiller même à
l'arrêt dans les bouchons il ya des
choses qui vont de soi y en a d'autres
qui équipe semble évidemment très
logique un fouiller dans la boîte à
gants écouter de la musique trop fort
aussi aujourd'hui il faut tout interdire
et légiférer sur tout alors c'est pas
une mesure de nouvelles c'est une mesure
du code de la route qui est ko est aussi
vieille que le code de la route et qui
s'appelle maîtrise du véhicule
on doit rester maître de son véhicule si
on est en train de manger un gros
sandwich à demain et puis conduit avec
les genoux on n'est pas en état de
maîtriser son véhicule ce que je
préférais rappelé et les nouvelles
mesures qui ont été prises au 1er
juillet que je voudrais pas dire des
interdictions mais des nouvelles règles
vous voulez vous allez peut-être en
parler mais il y a par exemple pour
rester dans dans ce que vous dites
l'interdiction pour ce qui concerne les
téléphones des oreillettes susceptibles
d'émettre du son c'est à dire en gros
les kit piéton des téléphones portables
mais aussi la musique la musique avec
une oreillette c'est désormais interdit
trois points 135 euros et le bluetooth
alors pour les pour les pour le
téléphone qui sont déjà intégrés aux
voitures il faudrait l'interdire aussi
celle abda prêt oui ce sera l'étape
d'après peut-être qui est déjà en
vigueur en espagne aussi qui l'espagne
est très en avance dans ce domaine là
ce qu'il faut bien comprendre que ce qui
est ce qui perturbe le conducteur c'est
la conversation téléphonique et la
concentration qu'il met à la
conversation téléphonique
c'est pas le mode de téléphone faudrait
plus parler à la personne qui installa
cotendo dans la voiture non plus mais ça
peut arriver oui effectivement
si vous êtes en train de vous lire et de
vous en regardant des sur la politique
avec votre voisin
ça peut vous perturber tout dépend de la
conviction qu'on met à la conversation
avec son voisin il faut bien de la
conviction en tout cas dans sa façon de
conduire la voiture les maîtres du v et
que merci d'être venu une nouvelle fois
sur ce plateau elle pour la prévention
routière faire un petit point sur les
différentes mesures et rappeler la
vigilance alors que le premier week-end
de départ en vacances vient de se tenir
si vous me permettez je l'avais oubliée
dans la mesure mais pour les jeunes la
lagune taux d'alcool dans le sang qui
était abaissée à 0,2 g parler autant
derrière le tourment dit rien du tout
quasiment autant autant ne pas boire du
tout ce sera encore mieux merci beaucoup
puisque nous parlions des routes
également cette information sachez que
des travaux sont en cours sur
l'autoroute a13 la société s apn des
luttes aujourd'hui la rénovation de 13
km de chaussée entre et poneys et poissy
jusqu'au 14 août des perturbations de
trafic sont donc après après avoir parlé
on passe aux sports est l'événement
l'open de france
90e 99e édition de cette compétition de
golf qui a livré son verdict dimanche à
guyancourt
l'autrichien wiesberg et 39e joueur
mondial a créé la surprise en s'imposant
pour la première fois le français à
victor dubuisson a lui terminé à la 12e
place et c'est une déception il a
longtemps a dominé les débats michael et
demi d'euros et mélanie poquet à l'image
de la météo caniculaire pluies orageuses
cette 99e édition de l'open de france de
golf a été totalement imprévisible avant
le tournoi les spécialistes de la petite
balle blanche parier sur le double
tenant du titre graeme mcdowell ou
encore l'anglais lee westwood
mais c'est finalement l'autrichien bernd
wiesberger 39e mondial qui a raflé la
mise
le viennois de 29 ans a conclu son open
avec une carte de 65 soit 13 coups sous
le par
une journée parfaite ponctuée par quatre
berdier la suite entre trou numéro 4 et
le trou numéro 7
je pense que je suis très chanceux
d'avoir remporté ce tournoi j'ai bien
joué sur ce beau terrain
un swing très bon j'avais confiance en
moi et c'est très important quand on
veut remporter des titres sur le circuit
monique lanzetta l'aise c'est un
magnifique d'acteur il a très bien joué
aujourd'hui il a fait un tour à -6 les
spécialistes apprécieront dans des
conditions bonne puisqu'il faisait beau
mais néanmoins chaude avec du vent il a
il a su maîtriser l'ensemble des
éléments sur un parcours de grande
qualité
le premier fond c'est michael lorenzo
vera termine à une belle sixième place
avec une carte de 68 devant victor
dubuisson la nouvelle star du golf
français 4e à l'entamé de la dernière
journée s'est totalement effondrée ce
dimanche il a réalisé une carte de 75
avec une balle dans l'eau dès le trou
numéro 1 et balle hors limites au trou
numéro 7
une journée à oublier pour le provençal
c'était une partie aurait besoin sans
aucune réussite malheureusement j'ai
raté un chef et un drive moyens qui sera
fini voilà c'est un peu le résumé ne
m'appartient et des choses positives
c'est sur mais bon c'est mon objectif et
pas à cette place là c'est un champion
il prend le départ c'est pas pour être
deuxième c'est pour être premier je
crois qu'il faut lui rendre hommage
parce qu'il a su animer le tout ces
partis hier aujourd'hui et on sentait
dès ce matin une volonté d'aboutir sur
la plus haute marche du podium
je suis tranquille ce n'est que partie
remise
victor dubuisson devrait revenir l'année
prochaine sur le parcours du golf
national et il tentera de s'imposer pour
la septième édition de l'open de france
de golf open de golf toujours et on
dépasse le cadre sportif à trois ans de
la ryder cup est l'événement prend aussi
une autre tournure pendant trois jours
un ministre un secrétaire d'état aux
sports sont venus visiter le site est
les écoliers aussi mis à contribution
avec un carnet de golf qui leur a été
distribué une opération pédagogique
unique en france catherine château un
ministre et un secrétaire d'état en
visitant ces quatre jours sur l'open de
france rien que cela et ce n'est pas un
hasard
le golf national de guyancourt va
accueillir la ryder cup en 2018
un groupe de suivi est constituée au
niveau ministériel c'est important pour
gouvernement que les choses se passent
bien et que véritablement la france qui
a une autre activité la france qui a un
savoir faire en matière d'organisation
de manifestations sportives
internationales
elle démontre à travers le golfe et à
travers l'open à travers la ryder cup
que nous sommes un pays qui qui est à la
hauteur des événements qu'on lui confie
de bonne augure avant l'introduction la
réintroduction du golf aux jeux
olympiques et paralympiques à rio de
bonne augure pour la candidature paris
dans l'organisation des jeux 2024 le
golf comme source développement d'un
territoire et le golf également comme
outil pédagogique des professeurs des
écoles des conseillers ont travaillé
pour mettre en place une manette autour
du golf à destination des élèves de cm1
cm2
c'est un document qui a pour vertu de
permettre le lien entre une pratique qui
est souvent trop réservé à certains
enfants certains élèves mais que nous
mêmes et nos partenaires de la
fédération française de golf ont
vocation et volonté d'élargir à d'autres
publics tirer parti de cette pratique
parce que on a
notamment dans la définition de
vocabulaire du golfe l'occasion de
pratiquer l'anglais
on a l'occasion aussi quand on
feuillette ce document de travail et sur
l'acquisition de données mathématiques
voire même aussi quand on fait un
travail sur l'histoire du golf
l'occasion avec nos élèves de travailler
des données historiques voire
géographique sept clips de formation
seront distribués dans toutes les écoles
des yvelines et une formation sera
assurée pour les enseignants une
première en france
actuellement 70 classes dans le
département bénéficie d'un soutien aux
activités golf et 2000 élèves ont déjà
pu pratiquer cette activité
je reçois présent le second invité de ce
journal tristan jacon soir et bienvenue
vous êtes élue à la vie associative
maire adjoint à magny les hameaux
aujourd'hui vient de reprendre dans
votre commune l'opération rtt et
remettez donc jusqu'au 13 juillet dans
le quartier du buisson
il ya des animations qui sont organisés
quel est l'objectif dans les grandes
lignes de ce rendez vous alors voyons
nine c'est un événement assez fédérateur
sur magny les hameaux puisque c'est un
élément qui collaborer avec avec les
habitants l'ensemble du tissu associatif
manie quoi et nos services municipaux
l'idée principale c'est de se sentir en
vacances avant le début des vacances
pour ceux qui ont la chance de partir et
on en parlera peut-être par la suite
qu'on nous avons d'autres
d'autres événements d'autres séjours qui
permettent à partir la chance de qui
n'ont pas la chance de partir tout à
fait c'est un moment fédérateur vous
l'avez dit sixième édition
il ya une implication véritablement des
associations locales ça se prépare
bien sûr on travaille avec lui depuis
janvier sur notamment la thématique
cette année c'est la thématique de la
lumière à l'aide d'élus maires s'étaient
déchaînées par l'unesco faire simple on
après 100 personnes qui vont être
mobilisés sur cet événement nous avons
50 personnes de nos services municipaux
et 50 personnes bénévoles de plus sur
ces 500 employés nous avons fait le
choix donc oui cinq emplois d'été ce qui
permet aussi aux jeunes qui qui peuvent
travailler qui veulent s'intégrer dans
notamment de professionnels d'avoir une
première expérience et à nous employons
ces cinq jeunes dans le cadre de
contrats de prévention notamment avec la
prévention spécialisée qui organisé par
l'association passerelle sur notre
commune donc il ya une dimension sociale
aussi d'impliquer les jeunes of the
north of notre travail sera situé dans
le quartier du buisson j'imagine que
c'est pas anodin
bien sûr c'est pas anodin après le
l'événement est ouvert à tout le monde
oman et quoi et on m'a dit quoi et au
quartier d'une pleine jungle et personne
qui habite aucun petit buisson et ceux
qui n'habitent pas effectivement une
dimension sociale les bailleurs sociaux
participent financièrement et on les
remercie à cet événement programmation
très riche on va pas faire tourner tout
le détail alors l'événement contre le
roi on avait quelques grands axes
effectivement nous avons un pôle pour
les enfants les bébés dès l'âge de 6
mois avec de l'éveil musical artistiques
de la peinture
nous avons un deuxième pôle équipe tôt
sur des sensations fortes
donc avec un bâtiment une structure donc
acquis assez surprenante troisième bol
qui permet de faire un sport qui à la
fin un mixte entre du hand ball et du
basket ball sur une structure gonflable
qui aura des éléments aussi en soit les
deux compétitions sur cette structure
nous souhaitons faire notamment si un
père simple impressionnante c'est un
saut sur un air bag g1 notation
structure ou sautaient dessus ça c'est
les ados qui recherchent les spéciales à
eux et nous devons aussi d'un futur
parti sur le travail sur la lumière donc
aider les théâtres et d'autres ateliers
artistiques ou un trait sur la lumière
et en partenariat aussi avec la maison
de l'environnement de saint quentin en
yvelines qui on l'espère sera encore
vers l'année prochaine petit message au
passage à travers ce message politique
forte fréquentation aussi en général à
peu près à 200 personnes par par journée
donc c'est une bonne jauge après il ya
des ateliers qui s'y prêtent engouement
qu on est sur des ateliers artistiques
notamment on va avoir déjoué un peu plus
restreinte notamment ce tir à l'arc
aussi nous on peut pas être 50 a fait du
tir à l'arc en même temps ça c'est pour
l'opération rtt vous l'avez dit c'est
une façon de se préparer un petit peu en
vacances et puis c'est une chance pour
ceux qui ne peuvent pas partir on va
commencer d'ailleurs il ya un feu
d'artifice aussi un le 13 août a fait la
fête nationale
ptt se termine avec une journée spéciale
samedi où il ya beaucoup plus aisément
que pendant toute la semaine le dimanche
nous avons un concours de tir et la
curieuse concours de pétanque excusez
moi qui ai organisé par notre
association de pétanque est
effectivement reprendre lundi avec la
fête de l'été et de la fête nationale
excusez moi et donc du coup le feu
d'artifice avec un bal et des
préparations culinaires qui seront
préparés avec des amis d'estaminet et le
réseau des changes donc des animations
jusqu'au 13
et après le 13 est ce qu'il ya un
accompagnement qui proposait quelle est
la politique de la ville en mettant les
règlements passer gentiment partent en
vacances par est donc en tout tout tout
l'été le service enfance avec le centre
de loisirs propose des sorties
le service jeunesse propose deux séjours
pour les ados de 6 à 12 ans de séjour
dont un premier séjour qui va être à
sologne qui va sur des activités plus
tôt plus sportifs un deuxième qui va
être en juillet sur une thématique
autour du futuroscope donc avec des
deals futuroscope des soirées
futuroscope et de la découverte plutôt
là sur la faune et la flore locales et
avec un peu de sport aussi vous avez
constaté une forte demande
année après année justement les gens qui
ne partent plus maintenant pas
spécialement pas sûr mais on est on est
sur ceux des constantes
après le ccs est docile et des famines
qui qui souhaitent avoir des aides pour
partir en vacances donc on a chaque fois
tout ce qu'on peut après y'a pas un
parent sont hideuses de photos de monde
et tout ça fonctionne grâce aussi à
l'implication des associations des
bénévoles ya une forte vie associative
ce sera ma dernière question celle à ses
partenaires mme annie elles se portent
magnifiquement bien on essaie de travail
que sur seulement un renouvellement des
bénévoles puisque l'association des fois
c'est souffle notamment au niveau des
bureaux et on sait travailler que cette
problématique mais on a la chance
honnêtement sur magny les hameaux
d'avoir un fort tissu de bénévoles qui
s'impliquent fortement dans la vie de
notre commune sur l'ensemble des
événements qu'on organise et vraiment on
peut on peut que les remercie et
notamment sur rtt
remettez donc merci des tristes en
attaque et il mise donc sur ces
différentes questions pour manier les
hameaux et c'est ouvert également aux
non manie quoi et manic oise
si vous voulez y participer une dernière
information pour terminer ce journal
secours populaire français dans les
yvelines organise une nouvelle fois des
séjours de vacances et des séjours
loisirs pour les plus jeunes l'an
dernier 95 enfants 71 adultes en ont
bénéficié soit 1922 journée de vacances
des actions ponctuelles sortie en parcs
de loisirs et découvertes également du
stade de bmx par exemple de saint
quentin en yvelines sont aussi
programmées et il faut des dons pour
faire fonctionner tout ça vous pouvez
les adresser à secours populaire point
fr slash 60,18 le journal revient demain
mardi aux horaires habituels à ripley et
des précédentes éditions de nos
reportages également à découvrir dès à
présent sur notre site internet et tout
de suite sur télé fils la dernière de la
saison de michael et demi d'euros le 7 8
sport à demain bonne soirée